let's go next to our caller from the
6:03 area code who's calling today from
603 hi my name is Eric New Hampshire hey
Eric what's up not much I just have a
quick question because of the pandemic
how wider will the separation between
classes become without any policy or tax
change if say Trump gets reelected and
you know everything becomes the way it
has been for the past three years how
far do you think the haves and have-nots
that separation won't grow I don't have
a mathematical answer but it's going to
grow and your I don't know know you're
asking a really important question which
is we are now seeing you know that
there's this implicit understanding of
blue collar and white collar that exists
you know the idea sometimes is made very
simple by calling it office work versus
factory work the reality is it's much
more complex than that right now you see
as I mentioned for example airline
pilots very much affected by what's
going on right now you see people who
work in restaurants but also people who
work in certain types of retail and even
people in certain areas of health care
that are being hit because they are
typically non-emergency healthcare etc
so we are going to smile at arguing yeah
I was more talking about the people that
are the shareholders of the airlines not
the pilots yep I mean I'm talking about
the ones that have the wealth yeah
you're gonna seize opportunities whether
you know but not the person that goes to
work the ones that tell the people to go
to work absolutely absolutely listen at
any time there is a cataclysm a crisis a
pandemic a natural disaster something
like 9/11
these are opportunities for speculators
and those who have are flush with cash
to make a ton of money with speculative
and non productive use of assets there
is no doubt about it
and you're completely accurate in that
there is going to be a widening income
gap a wealth gap rather as a result of
this because of people who are in a
position to seize some of those
opportunities totally ok great I mean
that's why I thought unless there is
policy or tax change of course - so like
one example now this is something Joe
Trump actually floated this but he
didn't do it which is what about
suspending the payroll tax for a certain
period of time the the Social Security
Medicare that would actually be an
interesting thing because if you I don't
remember exactly where the line is but
it's around 125,000 a year you only pay
Social Security Medicare up to your
first hundred and twenty-five thousand a
year in wages so people who earn a lot
more than that in wages or people who
are earning their money through capital
gains they're already not paying that so
suspending that would be a way to
directly do fiscal stimulus to people
who are actually mostly working for a
living it wasn't done right but that's
an example of a policy that we rolled
yeah I agree
all right call I very much appreciate it
and it's great to hear from our mostly
friendly neighbors to the north in in
New Hampshire